oh hey new season started what's been
going on wait what the heck yumushoku
tensei what the heck young Gojo what the
heck I have no enemies what the heck I
have no [__] yes the summer season is
upon us and while the rest of the world
is out there enjoying the sun I'm busy
in Japan bloody dying so why not stay in
with me and watch some summer anime we
got more isakai more romance more action
more Jiu Jitsu kaisen with young and
sexy Gojo oh god oh no
I can already feel the entire female
demographic now there is something I
must tell you
I came
once again there are so many anime to
watch this season so I appreciate any
tool that can make my anime watching
experience more convenient which is why
this video is sponsored by Opera GX
Opera GX is a new browser that might not
be for everyone but they're on a mission
to make surfing the internet a fun
experience for weebs of all shapes and
sizes the heart of Opera GX lies in its
customization options with GX mods you
can now find ways to flip your entire
browser 180 with one click and change
pretty much anything you want you can
pick one of many mods already added to
the browser or create a completely new
one that suits you most set your own
background music keyboard sounds opening
and closing tab sounds or play with the
themes and colors of the browser there
are even mods dedicated to setting
beautifully animated wallpapers
featuring some of your favorite anime
like this Luffy mod I've just chosen not
only do I get this sweet animated
wallpaper and color scheme just listen
to these keyboard and tab switching
sound effects
thank you
damn that's a 10. but I want to watch
anime no worries Opera GX and separate
videos from the browser into a floating
adjustable video frame you can catch up
to all the upcoming anime feature and
work or study at the same time with this
feature finally I could get through my
watch list there's even a dedicated
sidebar function that can play Tick Tock
videos or let you keep an eye on your
social media and messaging apps while
you simultaneously browse the net if you
love the game watch anime or Read Manga
then Opera GX is the browser that's made
for you click the link in the
description to download Opera GX today
for free and you know what this is going
to be perfect for watching the rest of
the summer anime by the power of this
command spell I order you
[__] yourself
alright before you start rolling your
eyes are you telling me I shouldn't be
excited about new boss of the Wars
action Focus Fade with Daddy Gilgamesh a
hype soundtrack from hiroyuki sawano
written by the guy that did bakino
and it's set in America
look at these idiots brand new magic to
a gunfight yes we have a Holy Grail war
and a land of bang bang and before you
ask where it fits in the timeline
don't worry about it all you need to
know is that it's fate A1 pictures is at
the absolute top of their game and
Gilgamesh is setting the tone with a
little playful fight by nuking Nevada
off the [__] map the dog the dog is a
master the dog's someone [__] hanky
dude how does a dog have better got your
life than I do can the sequel Corner we
once again have a bunch of Heavy Hitters
Jiu Jitsu kais and his back looking as
good if not even better than I did
before it's a new director this time but
I am loving the different Vibes that
feel way more cinematic than it
previously did if the action can match
up to season one this might be a new and
improved Jujitsu kaisen and something
something Gojo is still doing sexy Gojo
things
[Music]
Side Stories more bungo stray dogs
revenge for the second season
huh nowhere in my crystal ball did I
expect a trashy Harem anime from 2017
that I thought only I remembered and
enjoyed to get revived who greenlit this
whose hand do I need to shake the second
part of bleacher's Thousand-Year blood
War KARK is here after possibly the
biggest glow up I've seen and shown in
history but you know what else is back
pink isakov baby yeah my boy is back yes
Rudy as you show them kick some ass
that's my boy where is he grind some
girl's panties oh God no whose man's is
this come get your mans this ain't my
man oh [__] did he just dispel a [__]
Bliss is that yes that's my boy that's
what I'm talking about no he's praying
to the panties now someone please for
the love of God come collect your mans
whose mans is this
[Music]
my saliva yeah that's what I meant to
say too here's the Dark Horse of the
season a supernatural detective show
featuring an immortal Gothic lady who
spends her days being smug and snarky
and looking down on people despite just
being a talking head in a cage
wood it's nice to see a real detective
series that is engrossing the banter is
s tier they found a way to make dialogue
scenes Dynamic and engaging without just
ripping off monogatory and actually
finding their own Vibe this is one of
the weirder ones this season but it
definitely has potential if you're in
the mood for a good old detective story
with a Twist speaking of genre twist we
got level 1 Demon Lord and one room hero
a Demon Lord revives from the dare to
take revenge on the hero that defeated
her only to find out that he now looks
like this yes we have rising of the
midlife crisis in another world with my
dad bod here's what happens when you
think your arch enemy was your typical
isakai protagonist when it turns out he
was just your typical isekai fan
and now for the next great hero of
humanity
he just like me for real there's records
of Ragnarok if a radiated Sakamoto desk
guy energy this one's not shown its
cards yet in these early episodes but
I've had a lot of good things about the
manga in this one not that I needed any
convincing because all you needed to say
was hey
tournamental we got an anime with a lot
of pretty boys in it oh I love these
videos so much
happy birthday where's the men kissing
reborn as a vending machine now I wonder
the dungeons oh God they really have run
out of visaco ideas
wait why is this actually kind of good
all right stick with me here I went into
this ready to clown this show into
Oblivion but somehow this is a pretty
comfy and well thought out anime that
highlights Japan's vending machine
culture if you think this is a dumb idea
with no demographic tell that to the
thousandth Tick Tock about a random
Japanese vending machine with millions
of views this has way more thought I
never put into it than a show about a
guy being reincarnated as a vending
machine should and with bradio singing
the opening I will take this show any
day over stuff like my unique skill
makes me op even at level one all right
you know what I need a quick Twitter
break so I'm gonna let chargpt take over
this one we've got a new a sekai call my
unique skill makes me op even at level
one about a dude called ryota who got
transported to another world after he
died by being tired but it turns out
even though he is level one the guy is
actually super overpowered because of
his ability to get good item drops okay
what's next oh wait I forgot to wash my
hands we've got a new a sec I call the
great cleric about a dude called luciel
who got transported to another world
after he died by gun but it turns out
even though he is healer and the world
hates healer the guy is actually super
okay perhaps I'm being a bit too harsh
you know what I gotta think positive
maybe the next isakai I watch will
actually make me proud to be an isakai
fan
foreign
maybe this is it maybe this is the
moment I finally hang up my fantasy
anime boots I don't think there's a show
left I could possibly come to my rescue
now
what is this a love life spin-off set in
a fantasy world that actually looks
really decent is this is this where I
start my descent into the love life
rabbit hole no
you swore to destroy the love life fans
not join them I shot I mustn't no matter
how good this looks you hear me Loveline
fans I see what you're doing tempting me
down the devil's path you think me to be
weak but I shall remain strong
I shall remain strong
I won't be tempted leave me alone
[Music]
poor cat is depressed again oh hey it's
me I am masterful cat the masterful cat
is me
okay but seriously what is a simple
Slice of Life show about an oversized
cat becoming a house husband looks so
extra there must be a oh it's you of
course it's you yes this is coming from
Studio go hands the studio that made
scenes like this and this normally you
can tell when they work on something
because they'll have scenes I can only
describe as the most technically
impressive visual vomit I've ever seen
but it seems like they've dialed it back
for this one I think it's better for it
this is just a comfy innocent show
that's actually as pretty as Gohan's
thinks it is in their head good on you
guys for Learning and finally showing
some restaurants are you sure about that
I think I'm gonna piss some people off
with this I didn't like this one I can
talk about Gohan's doing what I think is
the animation equivalent of making your
first PowerPoint presentation and using
star wipe for every slide transition
because you think it makes it look cool
but outside of a few shots generally
this looks really good because even
ignoring that as a man with shitty
eyesight this pushed my suspension of
disbelief Beyond breaking point because
dear God how does this girl constantly
forget her glasses when she's that blind
do you leave your house and forget that
you can't see girl please learn to wear
your contacts look into Lasik get on a
Mr Beast video because the only thing
worse in your eyesight is how hard this
guy is thirsting over you look I get
being obsessed with your crush but my
God the main character seems so hard
he's one date invoice away from turning
into kazuya from rent a girlfriend
forget the title The Girl I liked forgot
her glasses might as well call this
legally blind girl breathes air and
causes man to have panic attack yes it's
the dreaming boy is a realist and also a
stalker you know as a guy it can
sometimes be hard to read a girl's heart
I mean if you approach your crush and
she said allows you not to come near her
anymore she's just being tsundere right
what is this a restraining order
classic
[Music]
the most sane Cinder I enjoyer my tiny
Senpai more like my tiny Senpai ain't so
tiny if you know what I'm saying yeah
[__] this show now before you get up at
me calling me a Twitter Warrior I'm not
angry about the character designs I'm
just angry when I finally see a rom-com
not in school starring grown ass adults
in a workplace setting and they still
act like middle school students look we
all count on isakai for being the same
but tell me what the real difference
between these two shows are do you
prefer your gimmick to be having a
legally blind waifu or are you six foot
I want your girl to have the true 511
experience what's this well animated
non-cg dragons Griffins no Adventure
guilds and a magic school finally an
anime fantasy world that doesn't just
try to rip off Dungeons and Dragons
it just rips off Harry Potter I like
this one we're finally getting a
different fantasy world other than the
same copy paste World we've seen a
million times before with a bunch of
students entering a magic school where
20 of students either die get consumed
by work or go crazy was this a [__]
engineering degree yeah okay this is
definitely just Hogwarts but by adding
sword battles ninja clans and Mother of
God
dummy mommy Dumbledore this is about the
closest thing we've had to an actual
anime Harry Potter without breaking any
copyright infringement
okay now hold on there mister it looks
like JC stuff have actually pulled out
their A-Team for this one because this
looks way better than any show they've
done in recent memory this one's gonna
need a little time to cook it's a little
rough around the edges at times but I
reckon it can turn into something decent
if you look past some of the awkward
Exposition here and there
is where you use a sword go play with
the neighbor's kid mum says you'll have
fun mum says don't worry she's just a
normal kid mum says
I like dead people mom what the [__]
horror anime doesn't exactly have the
best track record even if it has high
production values and good animation so
I'm always cautious going into an anime
like dark Gathering don't get me wrong
this looks well animated and has done a
decent job at building up the unsettling
tone of the supernatural stuff behind
the scenes but I'm not sure how scary it
can be I don't know if this is meant to
be a horror or a comedy or both but what
I do know is that I'm not sure this QC
art style will be able to sell me on the
horror aspects of it I'll give it a few
more episodes but either way it'll
probably be better than the ginger anime
we've gotten so far
there's a world coming down towards me
probably huh it's a show called my happy
marriage maybe there's something in this
I can try in my own marriage
Hey Sydney
this is fine ah nothing says happy wife
happy life like growing up with a shitty
dad an abusive stepmom an abusive
stepsister and finding out you're having
an arranged marriage with your fiance he
tells you to kill yourself LOL sorry
what was that girls
yeah I thought you'd say that honestly
this looks like it could be pretty good
I don't know if they're trying a bit too
hard to make her shitty family Disney
villain levels of cartoonishly evil but
it's just nice to have an adult Shoujo
romance kinema Citrus are also knocking
out the park with some gorgeous visuals
and music that slaps harder than
her stepmom too soon too soon two
episodes in and I can already tell this
is gonna be one to get the tissues out
for and wait I thought this was meant to
be a period drama Cinderella Story why
are there ghosts monsters supernatural
abilities and a goddamn power system
what is this commitsuno 90 Day Fiance
all right next up we got Temple an anime
where a guy joins a temple
um actually the show is called tempuru
all right Mr nahongo Josie but that's
just the kind of spelling of Temple
right it's almost like we have a reason
to officially translate words and titles
when bringing it overseas
God damn it honestly this feels more
like a mid-2000s harem anime than
anything coming out nowadays man decides
to live among life despite the father
that left him and never came back to be
fair he didn't leave for cigarettes this
time he just left four my man's out here
trying to turn no [__] into a
lifestyle choice and the universe is
testing him with impure desires of the
flesh don't let my man be horny he just
wants to be happy this is no
representation of Monk or Temple life
this is season one of no not no life
holy crap this is insane I generally
look forward to any anime where I've
previously made a video of its manga but
even I didn't predict that zone 100
would go this hard for an entirely new
studio I feel the production team
channeled every single bit of hatred
they had for previous companies into the
passion of this opening episode The
inventive use of colors the visual
storytelling my guy literally ripped the
black bars off his screen to change the
aspect ratio and introduce some color
into his dead end life every shot every
angle every scene from this opening
episode feels like an absolute Master
Class not just from an animation
standpoint but a direct standpoint too
this is pure cinema at its finest it is
the most impressive opening 20 minutes
I've seen all year the anime isn't just
living up to its potential it's smashed
right past it but how does it fare as a
zombie apocalypse story
yeah it's pretty accurate if you think
you're bored of zombie movies then Zone
100 proves that can still be originality
in a saturated genre and not be tell of
a guy who's finally able to live his
life to the fullest when the rest of the
world is already dead if you're sitting
in your office chair right now counting
down the minutes you can finally leave
your shift this is the show that was
personally made for you it is a love
letter for everyone stuck in a dead end
job grinding for a company they hate
where you feel your life is wasting away
and it's a wake-up call to do more for
yourself this is setting the standard
for the summer and I don't think there's
going to be a higher quality piece of
entertainment I'm going to be getting
this season all right I think that
covers everything I don't think I've
missed anything notable
hahaha
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too Alpha
Sigma author Curtis Eckstein basil
dysfunctional degenerate flabberwocky
ivido levados
misaka12315 Payne Patchett Pony Stark
Water Guys VT and everyone else my
patreon for helping to support you this
month guys if you didn't know trash
taste has released new merch and uh you
can see it right here actually I'm very
very happy with this one I finally
convinced the boys to make me a denim
jacket and whoo I am very very happy
with this look at the back right here
baby look at that I'm biased but this is
probably my favorite piece of merch
we've released so far this is a
prototype so this logo is going to be
way smaller in the final version you can
buy online but we also got more t-shirts
shirts and hoodies if that's more your
thing so yeah you can go to trash
taste.co if you want to check some out
yourself anyway though that's been it
from me for today I've been gigock and
I'll see you all next time